[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
cada día que pasa desde el inicio de la
guerra en ucrania suma en miles a la
cifra total de refugiados que huyen de
los bombardeos en busca de seguridad y
los que no logran cruzar fronteras
también se desplazan dentro del país las
imágenes que deja el éxodo muestran a
mujeres hombres y niños lejos de sus
hogares siendo los menores una población
especialmente vulnerable en este
conflicto por lo que la recepción en
otros países es primordial este es el
mapa que detalla hacia dónde viajan los
refugiados polonia hungría y eslovaquia
reciben a la mayoría esto según la
agencia de la onu para los refugiados
desde que estalló la guerra en ucrania
la huida es masiva y se produce en un
tiempo récord tanto así que es la crisis
de refugiados de más rápido crecimiento
en europa desde la segunda guerra
mundial nuestras enviadas especiales a
ucrania prepararon el siguiente informe
sobre esta movilización
i
encontramos a artur y kiril en la ruta
hacia el este de ucrania han huido de
gosto mel ciudad al noroeste de kiev
donde se encuentra un estratégico
aeropuerto y buscan un lugar seguro en
el que resguardarse pero no es fácil
estresa
hearts of fans es difícil encontrar un
sitio seguro en el cual vivir
safeplace place to live
sol
yo lo he encontrado pero mucha gente no
lo puede encontrar y no sabe qué hacer
and find puesto life and done nuevos
todo aterrorizado por lo que han vivido
artur y kiril quiere retomar el camino
rápidamente para esquivar los atascos
kilométricos en las zonas rurales
alejado de los bombardeos el éxito de
personas es masivo
en la abarrotada estación de este grupo
de mujeres están luchando hacia polonia
cuentan que han viajado solas porque los
hombres no pueden abandonar el país por
una decisión del gobierno ucraniano a
causa del conflicto
en astún papel nuestra casa fue
bombardeada y las ventanas y puertas
quedaron hechas trizas
nos salvamos solo porque no estábamos en
casa por eso estamos vivos tuvo
mamocracia cuál está muerto las bombas
también han aterrorizado por días a andy
un estudiante nigeriano quien acaba de
llegar de schumi gracias a un corredor
humanitario
estoy intentando salir de aquí poder
dormir y ver qué hacer luego con extra
artur kiril angélica y andy son los
rostros de una crisis humanitaria que
crece cada día y se asuma más de 2
millones de desplazados ucranianos en
las dos semanas
moldavia es otro de los países de
acogida aunque este es el destino
inicial de algunos refugiados no hay
claridad para ellos sobre lo que pasará
después reporteros de france24
acompañaron a una familia que encontró
apoyo en una organización liderada por
un francés residente en el país la
historia a continuación
mucho desde que comenzó la guerra
thierry acoge a los refugiados
palanques del principal punto de entrada
para los ucranianos procedentes de las
grandes ciudades del sur
cada día miles de ellos cruzan la
frontera
ante semejante éxodo este francés que
lleva 12 años viviendo en moldavia dice
que quiere ayudar con lo que pueda
son iguales una familia de siete
personas quieren ir a polonia pero no
tienen dinero no tienen nada así que
tenemos que ayudarles
su organización ofrece refugio y ayuda a
esta familia que huyó de los bombardeos
en mykolaiv con pocas de sus
pertenencias
data tanto
los socios que unos comunistas société
con así es
aquí se van a quedar unos días para
estar atentos a sus familiares que se
quedaron en casa
lanaspa civil y nunca
dirá
y esa otra móvil ya él
[Música]
no
faltan poquitas
dentro de unas horas se pondrán de nuevo
en marcha hacia el oeste con la
esperanza de volver a ucrania una vez
retorne en los tiempos de paz
antes de la guerra en ucrania había ya
una necesidad urgente por ayuda
humanitaria según la oficina para la
coordinación de asuntos humanitarios
unas 29 millones de personas precisaban
apoyo por lo que el éxodo y el
desplazamiento interno agudizan aún más
la situación de los ucranianos y el dato
de migración de la semana
un refugio para mascotas que se quedaron
en ucrania por la guerra este lugar en
la frontera con polonia recoge y
alimenta a los animales de compañía sin
hogar aunque muchas personas huyeron con
sus mascotas no todas pudieron hacerlo y
algunas familias esperan volver a
encontrarlos cuando retornen
están muy traumatizados y estresados
algunos de ellos son perros callejeros y
nunca han estado al cuidado de humanos
otros son perros de familia que se
quedaron solos y a veces traen una carta
que dice esperamos poder encontrar a
nuestros perros y gatos nuevamente estoy
muy emocionada porque esto es muy
difícil pero hasta que inmigrantes de
france24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 sigan con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]